we should not all be suffering from some
uh you know
naive person's
uh attempt to do something on their lab
bench that just so happened to you know
walk out of the lab on their shoe or in
their lung
yeah
yeah it and then it um
so
the thing i've been struggling with
covid wise
is
is the degree to which then that error
was seized upon
really quickly by some people who seemed
almost quite ready for it we know they
were right they were doing these event
201 trainings if people don't know what
that is they would bring together a
bunch of
interested parties who would talk about
how would we manage a a viral outbreak
across the globe right and and so who do
they bring in that room well you're not
invited i'm not invited i don't think
any scientists are in there it's like j
and j executive some people from the cia
every major news media outlet bill and
belinda gates foundation um you know etc
and and and they bring them in and when
they ran those events what was startling
to me brett was watching that they they
never i don't i i watched a whole thing
and i didn't see them ever go here's how
we limit the loss of human life they're
like
you know there's this bad narrative that
might get out and people are going to be
spreading misinformation and they had
sub teams and here's how we would
control the narrative and it was really
just all about how do we control this
thing
but back to our point
when you unleash a virus on the world
like this it is fundamentally an
uncontrollable it's going to do things
it's going to get out and do what it's
going to do it's good virus is going to
virus right and
and it's done that it's made new
variants it's it's uh it taught us that
putting a leaky vaccine
into a pandemic was a really bad idea
like gear vandenboch said it would be um
and on and on and on and we got
thank goodness that omicron came along
we could have a different conversation
about that but what's astonishing to me
is how many people
were gleefully anticipating this exact
sort of an outbreak so that they could
do the kinds of things they wanted to do
like
ovid passports and
shutting down sectors of the economy
right
getting us to think that it was in our
interest to surrender our rights that
the key to accessing our rights was
surrendering them right these kinds of
upside-down
bits of logic and
um you know i i fear that
one of the facets of the game that is
about to unfold is
interrupting the natural process of
learning that people and societies go
through
what do you mean what i mean is the
lessons here are fairly obvious i mean
for one thing if this you know it let's
imagine that this happened at a much
smaller scale or that something
analogous happened at a much smaller
scale you know a town
right and people had been very very
wrong and they had been very very
convincing and
a disaster of one's size had been made
much worse through
uh their inaccuracy
right there would be a discussion and
the discussion would say well
i don't know how you got it so wrong and
frankly i don't know why you listen i
listen to you but i do know
that you're not the expert on this
anymore right your advice caused us to
harm ourselves you are now the last
person we will go to for advice on these
kinds of situations right and those
people that we went after
that we tried to to silence because we
thought that what they were doing you
told us that what those people were
saying was dangerous to us and that we
needed to silence them and we needed to
punish them right
you were wrong and in fact it turned out
they were right so believe it or not
i'm going to them next i'd like to know
what they see doesn't make them right
but it does mean that they have a
toolkit that has proven out
we are going to be prevented from
learning that lesson
we are going to be prevented from
understanding you know effectively as
much as possible will be driven to a
muddle
that does not produce the proper
reaction to correct the process so
exactly the thing that we were talking
about earlier that makes a biologist
smarter where you walk into a system you
know nothing about
you take your best shot you see what
worked what didn't and your model that
you carry around in your mind gets
improved by
uh you know by just simply actually the
human desire to figure it out right the
human desire to figure it out says damn
i thought that prediction was going to
be right why wasn't it you know i want
to be right next time whatever it is
that process would upgrade our thinking
but that's bad business
this happened for a reason you and i
don't know what it is let's assume that
it started with a well-intentioned but
crazy research
uh project that got out of hand
collapsed uh many of the functional
structures of the world
and
that the right thing to do now is to
figure out holy crap what did we do
wrong what's what's wrong in our
granting process what what's wrong in
our governmental agencies what's wrong
in the kinds of projects that that
exists what does dual use mean
should there be
this dual use argument right you can
study how to cure diseases with
dangerous viruses as long as they also
have some utility as weapons what
none of this makes any sense so
um i don't know whether there's any
stopping
the
uh
the process that is about to recapture
the narrative and steer it into some
um
ineffectual
state
but i do think that this is something
that we have to focus on because
everything is riding on this i mean you
and i both have children
right they're going to have to have a
planet that functions and the power to
cause catastrophes like this is going to
grow so our wisdom and how to prevent
them from happening needs to as well
even if you know this just freezes our
knowledge in place that's a disaster
so
i don't know we we've got to get better
at this and we've got to get good at
recognizing
that there's a spectrum of possibilities
about what actually happened here right
the story that you described there i
think is probably
at least partially true where people
when they saw this thing emerge they had
plans already in place to allow them to
capitalize on it
right to use it for things they wanted
to do anyway right for making tyrannical
incursions into our rights right they
had that on their agenda and they needed
a way to do it and suddenly oh covet
that's it all right let's do that
so we need to
we need to recognize the possibilities
and
i think
good healthy dose of agnosticism about
what has taken place is important
because it may be actually that there's
more to this than we know
i yeah the the idea that
you mentioned is about what what kind of
world are we leaving behind here for the
kids um
it's
so i'm of an age where i remember
what the world looked like when i was a
boy because i was out i was i was called
nature boy i was always outside
and i delighted in just catching things
um turtles snakes frogs fish uh insects
whatever um so i was out there and i
didn't realize to me i just took it for
granted like this is the world i live in
right and i distinctly remember when i
we what my family's from has a summer
place upstate new york on a finger lake
and i remember as a boy
literally being
wonderfully frightened i love this kind
of frightening when you would turn on
the porch light and if you came back
later the screen door would be covered
with this like terrifying array of
things right giant walking sticks huge
staghorn beetles big sphinx and luna
mods it was just you know things banging
in that you couldn't quite resolve
in uh last five years
nothing like you can leave the window
open all night with a light on inside if
you get one lonely moth you know you're
lucky now
um so that level of horrifying change to
me
tells me that that we don't just need to
sort of like point out that anthony
fauci is a bad guy that what we need is
is if we're gonna if evolution you know
if consciousness can come in and help
redirect itself a little bit we've got
some growing up to do as a species like
like
covet can be a wake-up call and i think
it has been for many people but i think
it has to wake us up to something even
bigger than a failure of the cdc to be
an effective institution um it has to
wake us up to something bigger than geez
can we get a couple of better candidates
for president next time it's it's it's
much bigger than that and so that's i
don't know how to get at that yet at
this point in time but but that's really
where i'm steering my efforts is using
covet as a means of reaching people who
are ready to wake up
and and use our brains towards abundance
and regeneration rather than just
extraction and depletion
and and that's as close as i've gotten
to it i'm not remotely smart enough to
know how to begin doing anything other
than having the conversation and hoping
people are attracted to that and that's
what i see this year is about is
we have to have that conversation
because in my lifetime i've seen
the oceans have become almost sterile
and i'm using that word very carefully
compared to what they were when i was
yeah i've seen exactly the same thing
and this is you know you know it's funny
the folks on the center right who we end
up interacting with now
um are correct about a good many things
and this is one of the things i think
they're way wrong about and i think we
have to have that conversation with our
natural partners on both
left and right so that they
so that we can upgrade our collective
model and let me just be candid about
your observation about the insects i've
made exactly the same observation and i
i was a very
uh creature oriented kid too and so i
played a lot in nature as much as
possible and i caught creatures just
like you and i remember a world in which
a
drive a summer drive down the highway
resulted in
just an
awful
very difficult to clean up mess on the
windshield right the number of insects
that died on the windshield of your car
it was a real problem right they were
sticky and there were
products that were sold you know you
could read in a magazine products to get
the goo off your windows because it
wasn't an easy job but the point is the
world has changed
the oceans are
so much less diverse than they once or
or maybe diverse is the wrong word but
there's so much less in them right and
the number of insects is way down and
there are places you can go
where you used to hike and see you know
a diversity of birds you couldn't avoid
seeing it and now you see nothing and
here's the part i got wrong
i would have said as a as a 20 year old
that if the collapse of the insect
population was as severe as you and i
both know it is
that that would have had catastrophic
effects on agriculture for example
and i don't think it has i think
agriculture has
pivoted and it be it functions
differently than it once did it is a
much more
robust process
because it's high tech it's robust to
this particular insult it's feeble with
respect to many other things so for
example
the super crops right super corn
isn't super at all
right it's incredibly weak the point is
it grows
incredibly big if you dump fertilizer on
it but it's completely incapable of
growing you know with any sort of
natural competition in the absence of
those inputs so anyway we're living in
some system that didn't behave
according to the fears that i had
but nonetheless the collapse of the
insect population is every bit as severe
as we worried it would be and maybe more
severe so
i don't know we have to have the
conversation and we have to have the
conversation about what it implies right
and in some sense
the good news about covet 19
is that it showed
how vulnerable we are
and not just at the level of
our biology it showed how
vulnerable we are
to propaganda and to being induced to
viciousness toward each other
and to demonizing those who are trying
to tell us things we need to know
right so this was a trial run and if we
learned the lesson of it we could come
out of it much stronger but then again
that's the reason that i'm afraid the
lesson is going to be buried
so i'm keen on this like um
how how we get out of this and it's a
multi-step process so you you've you've
bumped into one of the aspects of this
for me which is the mass psychosis um
story mass formation more technically
i like the word psychosis because
well it's sort of more evocative but
but the idea that that there were a
group of people who fell prey rather
easily to
a a set of narratives that were
not just provably false but demonstrably
ridiculously previously provably false
but i understand the process that we got
here and it's disappointing to me
because
um these events that
we go we're spending so much time
in this mass formation event
and we're not using that energy for
other things that i think really need
and deserve our like full full full
attention
and there's so many i love how john
michael greer put it a long time ago he
said you know problems have solutions
that's fine we can all talk about
problems but predicaments
have outcomes
you got to manage those right so
so i see us facing a number of
predicaments and we have to decide as
adults how we want to begin managing
those
energy is a huge one when you look at
where we are in fossil fuel consumption
still plenty there it's not forever
when you really understand that what has
to happen at scale time cost
sociologically and culturally in order
to get there even if we have 50 years
you realize the best time to have
started this would have been back when
jimmy carter put the cardigan on and the
solar panels on the roof right
that would have been a great time and we
haven't and we've sort of dilly dallied
along so so i'm i'm worried that what
i'm seeing now is that they
have a really powerful set of tools to
distract people and keep us
focused on things that are of no
importance and i hope i don't piss off
too many people saying that but we have
been focusing we've been navel gazing in
this country
and on things that are fundamentally not
even on the problem scale let alone the
predicament scale in this right
so
i know a lot of people take it super
important that you know are there 50
genders or 60 i mean it's just like in
the scheme of things once you understand
what we're up against with with the
species issues and
with energy you might say okay
we'll put that on the list but it's not
it's not on my it's not at the top of my
priority list yeah i agree
i'm
you have to have traveled somewhere
that's really dysfunctional to
understand how much trepidation you
should have about disrupting a system
that works even if it has terrible flaws
that you dislike right
there should be trepidation about
upending a civilization that functions
and look
i'm a died in the wool liberal i grew up
in a liberal household i'm as troubled
by the failure of our system
to be
fair and decent as anyone but
the solution is to improve it the
solution is not to wreck it because we
invite
absolute catastrophe
by wrecking it and by concentrating on
things that shouldn't be at the top of
the priority list that is exactly what
we will do
so
i i wholeheartedly agree that that's a
tremendous hazard i will point out for
my listeners
that
mass formation psychosis suddenly became
a feature of people's thinking at the
point that robert malone talked about it
with joe rogan
you had had matthias desmond on your
program
because you saw how important this was
that was before
robert malone went on on rogan and
talked about it and it had been
a concept that was being circulated
amongst people who were thinking clearly
about this um before that so you saw
that this
bubbled into the conversation of people
who were making sense you recognized how
important it was you amplified it to
people who follow you
and then i don't know a month later
it became something that dawned on
people was important and what i would
point out is that this is a general
pattern there is a conversation of
people
who
stared down the stigmas that were thrown
at us
it's a much better smarter conversation
than what the public is being exposed to
right it's a conversation that sees
things coming right if you were paying
attention to
garet vandenbush then you know
that variance was an issue you were
thinking already about the insanity
of an absurdly narrowly targeted vaccine
that couldn't help but drive
uh the evolution of this virus to some
new place
you knew that it was nonsense that this
was going to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated that the variants were
going to be the result of the large
population of unvaccinated people you
knew all that way ahead of time and if
you're standing where they expect you to
stand you hear about these things late
you hear about them right along with the
phony debunk [ __ ] and you don't know
what to think and so part of the
question for people
who are trying to figure out how they
can protect themselves from this whether
or not civilization learns the lesson
how they can get smarter so that they
don't end up victims of this again part
of the question is how are you going to
figure out
what conversation to tune into so that
you'll see all of this stuff coming and
the the unpleasant answer to that is
the stigmas
the
vilification that was used to prevent
people from figuring out who to listen
to the point is when those of us who did
stand up were vilified publicly
that was to persuade other people not to
come near us it's too expensive you
don't want to do it
and
you know i can't say it isn't expensive
but i can say if you wanted to know what
was coming that was the way to do it was
to ignore those stigmas and listen to
people who were trying to warn you
[Music]